[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
I
I mean I just watched Glass Onion you
saw it Oh my God
same thing I can't even hold down I have
another thing to talk to you about get
into that right second I can't it's also
it's the walk it's the character it's
the vamp and it's so delicious to watch
do you love this character what's your
inspiration I love you in so many movies
like so many
the list is so long but this character
this new woman I don't feel like I've
met her before no she's new who is she
I'm so sad that you know it's like I'm
like I wish well there's not much I can
say actually yeah because it's like
because I still have to wait right it's
such a mystery the whole point of this
movie is it's brought the mystery genre
that's right you don't want to ruin
anything for anybody but playing birdie
J was one of the great joys for me and
you pull it off so brilliantly it's like
bam I love you
it's just so good
we have a clip uh from Glass Onion I
just got itchy that's how much I'm into
it I've got hives take a look
[Music]
oh my God we can't hug right I mean can
we all hug everybody
stay at the hotel last night I didn't
see you no Bernie we clearly just
arrived
but you hello stranger danger
[Applause]
as a little girl when your dream is to
be performing whether it be on a stage
or on camera you just want a hat it's
like just give me the hat and give me
you know give me give you the light and
the hat tip up like Ingrid Bergman in
Casablanca and you're just like yeah you
just never get those opportunities you
know yeah and and I got one with Penny
Lane going to Morocco at the end of the
movie I got a hat tip
and then Ryan gave me the hat and Miss I
was so happy I was like oh God I just
give me a hat I mean you are such a
like
[Applause]
we were talking about the Wilsons the
last time you were here we talked I
dated Luke I did it Owen did you ever
hear from one of them no neither did I
absolutely not and I don't think I have
either of their phone numbers I
definitely don't have their notes
because I was like if I might have
Luke's I might have Owens if he hasn't
changed his cell phone number
we should do it on the show
[Laughter]
oh my God I I think I think we should I
do absolutely I haven't I'm gonna have
you gotta have them on the show at some
point you know what it'll be supposed to
come on and then I think because of like
something like a film he had to be
thwarted typical Wilson I know I was
like is it really or did you just get
elusive
he needs the elusive Wilsons The elusive
yeah he does need to come on here
talking about I bet he's I bet he's
terrified he probably thinks like you
would just be so open yeah and he's not
so like yeah which is why it would be so
good
[Applause]
you gotta come on this show and by the
way you know me I'm not a gotcha person
we'll have so much fun you know because
like Justin Long came we did this I
asked him and I was like how do you mind
being the season premiere and he was
like okay like okay and I think it's so
fun to celebrate and Champion your exes
you may not have the same relationship
it's true do you guys think that's funny
and if so why what's so fun I was like
what is it
because no I agree with you on a serious
note
yeah I mean look we carry so much pain
and with like pain of relationships
ending and your ego and however you know
there's maybe usually someone who's
feeling a little more pain than another
yep and if you can't get past that and
you can't move past that you're just
holding it and like I think Love Changes
form you you don't just stop loving
someone agreed you know even even in the
worst possible scenario
meaning I mean well maybe a couple worse
that you know maybe there's a few toxic
old bags you got to get out of the
picture even in like relationships where
things can go really South yes I believe
there's always a way back to to
uh finding a place where you can have
compassion and still feel that love just
differently also I've made mistakes in
my past so you have I have never
I am perfect
which is why you're so forgiving
[Applause]
it's true it's like you know what man
you screwed up I screwed up we sometimes
you literally break up with nothing to
point to which is very hard and
confusing yeah you know sometimes
there's no Scandal or a particular
reason there's all different forms but I
also think red I I find it to be a red
flag when someone blames someone in a
relationship like if I meet a new guy
and he's like oh she's crazy or oh she
is I'm like oh I don't like that that's
not a good sign totally agree I
completely agree
I went on a date who trash talked his
ex-wife and then his like other ex-wife
and then the brother of anything oh
there's a problem kept going down the
line and I just thought you know what
did you do yeah what's your part in this
what is she saying about you I just was
like why are you such a Negative human
being and I actually like some of the
people I'm mentioning them because we
know them in common that's very bold
that you wouldn't even have the
sensitivity or awareness to think what
if I liked them how would I feel about
you coming at them with such heat but I
I just think this person was very devoid
of any awareness so I think that was
their problem to begin with but I
totally agree we should Champion our
exes like we should be able to and you
don't have to be best friends especially
if they have a new person in their life
you know there's no reason that any
relationship has to go so far that it
makes their new person uncomfortable
it's more of a I think it's weird to be
like as if this didn't take place or
happen and it becomes taboo that is
bizarre to me especially when you know I
Am Co I'm co-parenting with someone yeah
and although we not might not be married
anymore and he's even married with his
beautiful new wife Ali our wonderful
stepmother we're in a daily engagement
yeah and our relationship family has
never been better and it's a different
dream yeah I feel I feel the same about
I mean Chris is now Riders off to
college I can't we're not like writers I
know I know what happened and also you
look exactly the same as when you had
him so that's awesome
I was also like 20 I was 24 when I had
writers so I look back at those pictures
and I'm like oh my I was such a baby you
know it's kind of wild but
oh there's my fam oh oh yeah there it is
there she is oh my God look at me he's
so much taller I know oh my God I guess
that's what happens I know he's six one
oh my God yeah wine and I'm so happy
because I was always like right are you
like you gotta like do some cardio or
you know like teenagers get go to this
weird some teenagers some are athletic
and are constantly into it but Ryder's
like an artsy guy you know yeah I know
I'm like Ryder yeah he was like I'm like
go for a run like go work out or
something and you're like Mom please cut
it too he's just like he's like buff
he's into it like I I you know I rubbed
off on him I think a little bit he's
like working out everything can you rub
off on me please
you know all right we have to take a
quick break I'm gonna grab my phone
we're gonna prank a Wilson and we're
gonna come right back because we've got
some other fun stuff to talk about with
you right now
[Applause]
[Music]